el activista joshua won volvió a ser
detenido por las autoridades no es la
primera vez que la principal figura del
movimiento prodemocrático es arrestada
pero esta vez las autoridades lo acusan
de participar en una reunión ilegal en
octubre de 2019 y por llevar una máscara
en las protestas un acto ilegal hasta
antes de la pandemia en total podría
enfrentar hasta seis años de prisión
portis con el efecto escalofriante
generado por las autoridades de beijing
es el tercer proceso que tengo que
enfrentar desde que salí de prisión el
pasado junio cuando meto borja verne
hago esto dos veces pero pase lo que
pasa seguir resistiendo y espero que el
mundo sepa cómo los hongkoneses eligen
no rendirse pueden procesar nos
arrestarnos encerrarnos en la cárcel
pero no pueden censurar nuestro
compromiso con la libertad a boca a boca
miman contenido faith por frei dan pero
bueno no ha sido la única figura en
sufrir las consecuencias de la nueva ley
de seguridad que rige en la antigua
colonia otras figuras clave del
movimiento que busca rechazar la
injerencia de beijing en los asuntos de
hong kong
han sido detenidas con anterioridad como
el magnate de jimmy line o la activista
ahmed show algo que ha hecho que desde
hace semanas se pida su libertad
nos preocupa la situación de los
derechos humanos en china de cara al
próximo día nacional del primero de
octubre
esperamos que todos los disidentes todas
las personas reprimidas por el sistema
judicial chino sean liberadas de
pluralizar vuelve a release la conocida
revolución de los paraguas es un
movimiento que busca defender la
autonomía de hong kong respecto al resto
de china y desde mediados de 2019 su
lucha se ha intensificado contra el
poder central a pesar de las crecientes
restricciones impuestas